dude nothing will replace the moment
when we were at the buffet and we said
and I walked up to the dude serving and
I was like is this beef and he said it
should
be dude how about when we walked up for
the first time and they're like they're
like huh oh you guys want to eat
[Music]
here you guys remember the Apple um
$117,000 solid gold watch from a couple
years ago they had a Sol no I don't
remember that it's an Apple Watch that's
just Apple watch solid gold like [__]
you know looks like only had one Apple
watch that's gold one of one W no no
it's not one of one but it was just made
for like the highend it was just
something for that market it was
definitely like limited right yeah it's
a [__] 15minute battery dude the
Apple watch sucks I just don't like the
battery I got to charge it [__] every
day every day every single day we need
nck product reviews yeah nck product
review you need to get an ultra then
you'll be honest so two 2 and a half or
what well if you put on low power mode I
can go 3 days without Char that's an
eyew watch what is that Apple watch yeah
the ultra 7 Days baby 7 Days Seven Days
that a Fitbit a Fitbit but it doesn't do
half the things we do and you're with a
what are you you going to talk to
someone on the phone like this hey bud
what do you up to I have dude Power
Ranger [__] yeah pick up the phone
beat me up pick up the phone no
sometimes you're doing stuff so you're
just talking when you're do you know I
do I just I'll call you back you know
I'll just do that why you so angry all
time n dude it just you said you trying
to work on
your L you just got wrecked Anthony all
right dude I'll take that L you talking
in your phone let me be a example wow
all right so check it out I like that
with a nose STP talking on the phone
like what' you say you know and then
once you have a phone call for 10
minutes you it's now it's half a day I
thought that's advantageous for if you
do like a lot of Athletics so that hold
on give me a second I'm going to check
my mail real quick so imagine it's 2017
you spent $177,000 or 2015 you spent
$177,000 on this stupid [__] watch
right loser and guess what Apple just
said hey we're no longer going to
support these watches we're so we're so
sorry well that's probably not why they
bought it anymore what do you mean
support it they're not buying it to use
it all the time you can't you're
eligible for parts repairs you're not
going to get software updates you're not
going to get all the other just a shell
that's gold like can't you just get a
new Apple watch and swap it like a like
a phone case
I don't know oh okay man that's that's
totally standard it's like when you buy
a like an old car and it becomes vintage
you don't you know vintage from 2015
yeah but doesn't Chevy keep making parts
for it or whatever
thir but can you you could still pull up
to a Chevy dealer with a classic and ask
for an oil change they'll still service
it I bet there's like tons of Chinese
companies that
just you got a gold one come to me
that's pretty crazy we are orange we
will do it for you if you're going to
spend like 17 grand on a watch then
you're hoping that as it gets older it
gets more valuable oh yeah but with with
tech because Tech moves so quickly we're
at this exponential growth level of
things like battery life and [__]
like screen size or or resolution it's
kind of like this every [__] year
goes like this they're probably not
using it like a regular one right like
if you if you were like hey guess what
Apple I'm a die hard rider dude I'm
spending 17 GS to support your [__] and
all stuff they should make an exception
for you and not this like 7 years later
standard thing where they no longer
support things after a certain time cuz
how many people have those [__] watch
I mean it's it's on brand for apple is
it yeah they say we don't care we make
enough remember those colorful like
Apple Computers oh yeah if you have one
of those if you take it to the Apple
Store they'll still service it right I
think they I think they punt it out of
the [__] and they said get the [__]
out of here that garbage out of here a
vintage MacIntosh and go in there and
ask them to service it yeah that' be
[__] fun new iOS on it dude my buddy
Richard uh Ryan he's he's this this
YouTube channel called Full mag I
remember him buying like the new iPhone
when it first came out he shoots it with
a gun and then he walks it into apple
and he's like hey like you know can we
service this [__] thing and these
guys are like what the [__] I got Apple
Care he shot it with a 50 cal too so it
was
likeed yeah that' be tied if you could
buy the gold watch through like T-Mobile
payment plan
style oh my
God holy [__] it's like a car payment
now now their payments are you get the
15 for free with the two-year contract
for Verizon at an T-Mobile for for two
year dude a commercial that's not free
that's how to get you bro I need one
look at my phone dude I [__] dropped
it dude my that's right where ta's face
is it looks like ta's decapitated in
camera doesn't work on my phone dude at
that you can get that fix like 30
minutes I pay 30 bucks a month for
unlimited cuz I got Spectrum Business
what does that mean unlimit 30 bucks a
month for unlimited service okay yeah
for what service Spectrum for your phone
yep or cable my phone TV have any of you
guys bought the the Gold version of
anything or like the high-end version
that was like stupid to buy but you got
it um H remember the old iPod Nano what
is that think about it oh oh this how my
G-Shock is it really a G-Shock yeah I
never seen that in design yeah exactly I
love this do you remember those G-Shocks
that's something that's probably still
high in value G-Shocks Like Rappers
[__] used to all ice out their baby
G-Shocks and G-Shock the tech on that's
not going down it's the same true yeah
and you can run this over with a Jeep
and it's fine I love G-Shocks dudee
Prett cool yeah I love this thing but
yeah it's not real gold I do still like
my ultra it's a pretty sweet watch it's
pretty sweet how much would was it $700
maybe more yeah probably it was a
business expense nice cuz they you need
to know what time that's essential for
business so true your dance suit shoot
did you ever buy like a special edition
thing I think when it when it comes to
games sometimes they'll release like a
special special edition for like almost
like five times a price and if it's like
a franchise I'm a big fan of I'll buy it
but it just comes with useless [__]
it'll be like oh freaking art book of
the game artart and it's like soundtrack
of the game has anyone ever listened to
the soundtrack of the game not since
killer inant yeah well no some
soundtracks games are [__] cool but
do you sit there and listen to but
anybody who plays games is Tech saavy
enough to just bootleg it like it's or
it's just on Spotify yeah that's what I
was going to say it's just like a point
of Pride it's like oh I got the best
thing of the thing I like dude I
remember getting the bat remember when
Batman Arkham Knight came out I was like
[__] it I'm getting the special edition
whatever I love these games and then
when I got it like I put the Batman it
was like a Batman statue the kind kind
of lights up and [__] and Nikki's
like you're such a [__]
idiot Arkham KN was sick it was sick
though Arkham KN was really good such a
good game I like getting the best room
in the shitty hotel
like how much is that man it's crazy all
right at the Rio the Rio with the
buffest bed
bugs you know the real in Vegas right
yeah should be it used to be the [__]
best when we were kids right when it was
new right when it was new was it ever
the best no there was a time when in the
late '90s people will remember the real
buffet was the real Buffet yeah it was
like people will remember they will
remember they will remember everyone
will
know the Legends are true I remember
when everyone went and they raved about
the real Buffet the seafood buffet was
legendary there was no wind Buffet true
there was no [__] bakanal that was
the place to be this also coming from
the guy who like forced us to all eat
circus cus was like this was the
one everyone will know I'm so glad we
did that that was fun it was a very sad
Buffet but it was fun it was really bad
and well we also had the real Buffet
when it went downhill and it wasn't the
same but the thing is they used to have
[__] free Carnival shows like they
had floats it was crazy so I remember
that as a child they had rooms Penthouse
rooms with a [__] bathtub overlooking
the Las Vegas that's pretty cool all
this [__] for $70 a night what yeah
recently that's crazy did it from my
honeymoon wa y wow 70 bucks for their
best room yes because there's only like
six or seven murders in those rooms over
the last 20 years walk in with a hasmat
sear yeah it's like a th000 s ft room
and when we were in there it just felt
like I bet you LL Cool J had orgies in
here like you know it was like everybody
knows it was it felt like that kind of
room that's the artist you chose cuz it
was popular in the '90s if you booked
that for 30 days that's only 2100 you
could just live there as rent I know
that's crazy yeah wow yeah full service
month yep so that's so that was the
thing is I wanted to go up and down
Vegas to all of the hotels that I oh
cool yeah I could have stayed as a sweet
cuz we stayed at the Motel 6 so I want
to go Circus Circus but give me your
best sweet and you probably could get it
for like a 100 bucks or so when we at
Circus Circus remember when all the
water was just [__] draining oh my
God the giant flood like just leaking
out the ceiling and we were the ones
that pointed out to work like hey I
think you got a water problem he's like
get the [__] out of here what you snitch
a little bagio going on dude nothing
will replace the [__] moment when we
were at the buffet and we said and I
walked up to the dude serving and I was
like is this beef and he said it should
be
dude how about when we walked up for the
first time and they're like they're like
huh oh you guys want to eat here oh I
guess you better cook I how do we do
this yeah the plates are over here I
think dude do when you guys see shows do
you get the best seats or sports games
or anything do you get best seats I get
the cheapest
[__] deals me baby I don't know no I
just go for a good deal bang for your
buck yeah cuz I try to get the best
seeds they're [__]
expensive I like the I did though for
Nikki uh for one of our anniversaries I
got her front row at Eminem I like row
there was nothing between us and Eminem
that's sick yeah and she was like losing
her mind it was it was great watching
her watching her like literally reach in
her pants and jerk off to another guy
was awesome that's the only time you'll
cck huh time my life you go home and
[__] after really hard cuz she's
thinking about Eminem yeah and I think
about what a cuck I'm being yeah it's
kind of hot yeah super
[Music]
hot